look at bailey over made four starts
this season he's done a very good job
doesn't get himself in trouble his
height helps him be deceptive
off the middle
backhanded by polanco and a dig at first
by kerala going away
high fly short right field
coming in is kepler
two down two innings last night no hits
to walk
all right fastball gets him that's how
how ober goes about his business a
hitless scoreless first inning really
nice body of work overall for wade miley
his record really ought to be a little
better than six and four
but he does everything that you want him
to do
turned on
well hit to left on the run tyler naquin
shades of the ball he tracked down to
the left center yesterday
and he's so hard to square it changes
their defense
swing at a miss
drilled and that's past the reach of
suarez into the corner
crews barreling around first he's got a
double
we'll take a big turn there
and get back
broken bat bouncer left side farmer
comes in gloves throws on the run in
time to get larnick and the inning is
over
the shift on suarez and the first pitch
of ground ball the third cino will back
handle set he'll go to second for one
the return will be late
runner goes big lead now ober steps off
he'll throw to second base simmons has
the runner in a rundown kirilov chases
him back to second feeds polanco and now
he's tagged out
fly ball center field celestino hustling
in and he makes a diving catch in center
alberto celestino
doing his best byron buxton
impersonation
this pitch is hit high in the air left
center field moving over is naquin he's
calling for it he'll get there to make
the catch
uppercutted
adjusting against the sun two down
grounded india
one two three
the number nine hitter in today's reds
order that'll be tucker barnhart
and barnhart gets into that one
shoots it to pretty deep right field
kepler retreating no play that's god
just beyond the flower pots in right
field
tucker barnhart goes deep and the reds
stand on top one to nothing
squibbed off the end of the bat
and
over flips
and carol up bear handing it some
confusion between the pitcher and the
first baseman and carol off says take a
look at it they're going to challenge
this a little in between but look at
this little great instincts right here
on this glove flip and
girl off actually bare-handed this ball
i don't know if that's going to get
overturned or not no they may get that
overturned if the interpretation is the
ball has to get to the back of the glove
right well in this case the back of the
bare hand and they do call him out
picked up by polanco and he throws him
out
jorge polanco with a great play from
short right field he is one of the
lowest hard hit rates in barrel rates in
the game
and that's in their strike three called
two k's for miley both at kepler's
expense
and now miley goes to the off speed gets
a swing at a miss three strikeouts for
miley jeffers flew out to left field is
only at bat
jeffers to the left and he got all of
this one jeffers just missed a home run
in the second but he barreled that one
up and the twins take a two to one lead
pauses at the belt now delivers and
india takes just off the inside edge
just gonna load him up with nobody out
for winker
shoots that one high in the air deep
right field leap at the wall off the
glove in a double for kiriloff the race
is on farmer scores barnhart given the
wave india over to third barnhard
crosses the play the riders roll it's
3-2
reds so the reds have loaded the bases
again here in this fifth and now suarez
sharp ground ball through the whole base
hit one run is in they'll send a second
the throw from lornak to the plate there
and plenty of time
and winker's tagged out base running
mistake by jesse winker he's going to
wave over there to jr house and say yep
that's on me
broke his bat india has to wait on it
tumbles on the shovel
does recover to at least get kirill off
farmer on the cover
and celestino first ball swinging lifts
one to
the right fielder
castellanos who steps back a couple
makes the catch
swing it a miss
bend the knee jorge polanco
pick at third by sano
two away
[Applause]
ceno's come up with two really good
plays at third base
and now he hits him with a pitch
and cruz
limps out of the box
he and miley have had a little uh fun
with each other i think i hope it's fun
the 1-1 breaking ball hit to left going
back on it naquin and he will square up
as he makes the catch
swinging a miss wow
from 3-0 to a strikeout of a man who
took him deep two runs allowed through
the first six by wade miley
center field akiyama
popped up right side
backing up stevenson continuing to back
up and he lunges over his shoulder and
makes the catch two down
swinging a miss and he struck him out
and that makes that
seven innings of two-run baseball for
the reds left-hander wade miley the reds
have him at the corners for kyle farmer
grounded left side pass
naquin plunges at the plate ahead long
slide over to third shoots akiyama
backside farmer up to second the reds
expand the lead to five two it's now
five to two so now second and third one
out barnhart trying to blow it open
barnhart gets on through again it skips
into right farmer right on the heels of
akiyama barnhart shoots a couple more
home and the reds cruising now up a
comfortable five spot
so now max kepler will bat with one on
and nobody out
a drive right center field headed to the
scoreboard
and gone a two-run home run and the
twins jump back into the game they go
for three today over his last eight
and the one-o pitch a drive to right
field and deep beckett goes deep it goes
we have a two-run game
obliterated out to right field it's a
7-5 reds lead and now miguel cino
represents the tying run in a two-run
game the old two pitch a line drive into
left field naquin back it's going to be
over his head and gone no it's in play
off the top of the wall stopping at
third base is jefferson to second base
on a line drive that hit the top of the
wall and that is going to be off the top
of the wall kirloff this season with
runners on base is batting 400.
drive right center field deep to the
scoreboard it'll tie the game carol off
to second with a two-run double
who has reached all four times 2-1
naquin shoots it deep left center field
that's gonna carry and that's gone
a three-run homer a four-hit day for
tyler naked 10-7 lead in the night
the man at the plate can't even tie you
broken bat
suarez
ball game well done
the reds win the finale of a nine game
road trip they split the set into
minnesota
as they take down the twins with a
couple of three spots in the last two
innings a 10-7 finish